barate banque anja expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université donc des
secteurs c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur sautoir bonsoir baratte
pendant qu'annie à merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors selon
le journal économique britannique 1 le
bilan sanitaire est largement
sous-estimé cet article fait-il beaucoup
bruit outre-manche d'une tigresse cause
de cet été comme ça mais c'est certain
cela a suscité des inquiétudes que nous
savions que nous aurions trop
sous-estimé le nombre des morts cela ne
fait aucun doute
lorsqu'on ile-de-france poteau compte
les personnes à l'hôpital et au sein de
la communauté lé nord dues à d'autres
causes à l'hôpital ainsi que au sein de
la communauté effet chinois ont failli
quand certains datent de l'année par
rapport aux années précédentes
qu'on a une sur mortalité supérieure à
ce qu'ils ajoutent que les années
précédentes
effectivement je suis navré de voir le
dire le nombre sont bien plus élevés que
les taux officiels pour le moment et
comment l'expliquer parce que on le
rappelle le delta est quand même
extrêmement important selon le journal
ce chiffre s'établirait autour de 41
mille décès comment l'expliquer selon
vous
malheureusement ça temps libre de série
morts c'était comme un atout dans un
registre faut un certain temps pour que
le bureau national des statistiques qui
tiennent le nombre de personnes mortes
au sein de la communauté
de plus certains décès liés à des causes
inconnues cela il faut ré s'agir du
corps en à virus ou d'autres causes
comme il nous ne testons pas
systématiquement la communauté il est
difficile de dire
en or est directement liée aux
coronavirus dans de nombreux cas c'est
également lié au cours d'un virus pensez
vous que cette erreur entre nîmes et
c'est comme ça qu'on va l'appeler soit
faite avec l'aval du gouvernement
à donington historic bonnes études ne
pourrait pas vraiment dire qu'il s'agit
d'une erreur mais cela nous montre
effectivement que notre système de
décompte du nombre des cas au sein de la
communauté et au sein les hôpitaux ainsi
que dans les maisons de retraite
je trouvais pas suffisant les pas assez
précis n'est pas assez rapide grâce à
une nouvelle technologie pouvait être
plus efficace et recueillir des
week-ends de données plus efficace plus
meilleur et nous devons faire mieux
est-ce qu'à l'instar de la france à
aider c'est en maison de retraite sont
comptabilisés au royaume uni les décès
dans les maisons de retraite sont
comptés si elles sont enregistrées
mais il ya un délai ils peuvent être
comptabilisés comme une ode mort en
raison du grand âge et on peut indiquer
que le coronavirus a contribué à la mort
mais dans ce cas on ne dit pas que c'est
une mort dieu comme un virus
donc il peut y avoir des
sous-estimations en fonction du
certificat de décès le gouvernement
britannique a démenti mercredi manqué
aujourd'hui donc manqué d'infirmiers
pour l'hôpital de campagne géant ouvert
récemment à londres pour faire face à la
pandémie
restez donc très peu utilisé et
contraint selon le guardian de refuser
des patients
on sent qu'il ya beaucoup de suspicion
boris johnson était malade on l'a un peu
épargné mais et beaucoup de suspicion
envers le gouvernement britannique
oui je n'imagine ce secteur public
prospectus indécis ce résultat a été
créé dans une chance et c'est une
nouvelle expérience il nous attendions à
ce que beaucoup de personnes et besoin
de soins hospitaliers
d'après les nouvelles et les projections
sommes pas certains si les modèles
étaient exactes
donc or nous vraiment besoin d'autant de
nuit dans cet hôpital mount eagle
l'avenir nous le dira pour le moment on
ne veut pas simplement un hôpital on
veut piquer avec du personnel
supplémentaire pour gérer l'hôpital un
hôpital sans personnel ne sert à rien à
l'opposé la l'opposition briguent un
personnel l'opposition britannique
dénonce également les les lenteurs du
gouvernement est ce que c'est un
reproche que vous partagez cette
politique et je suis déçu les experts
moi ou d'autres demandent depuis très
longtemps
où sont les équipements de protection
personnelle où sont les matériels de
test où sont les personnes à qui feront
les testeurs nous avons effectivement
l'impression que quatre à six semaines
en tout cas est gâché nous aurions pu
nous préparer bien en avance donc cela
est très décevant je dois être honnête
merci baratin degania expert en maladies
infectieuses d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france depuis le royaume
uni